What can 20 years do to you? Well, consider the case of George Ryan, former governor of Illinois, lifelong Republican. Ryan is famous for one of the most dramatic flip-flops any big league politician has made in this country on an issue in the last few decades. In February 2000, Ryan, a death penalty supporter, tough on crime, declared a moratorium on the death penalty in Illinois, the first state to do that in decades. You may have heard about that. And he's spoken about that decision in public a lot.
20年能改变你多少？好吧，考虑一下伊利诺伊州前州长、终身共和党人乔治·瑞安（George Ryan）的案例。瑞安因该国过去几十年来大牌政客在某项议题上最戏剧性的立场反转之一而闻名。2000年2月，作为死刑支持者、以打击犯罪著称的瑞安宣布暂停伊利诺伊州的死刑，这是几十年来第一个这样做的州。你可能听说过这件事，他也在公开场合多次谈论过这个决定。
But we found this recording of a speech that he made at Northwestern University, one of the rare times that he's talked about his decision so personally and emotionally. And among other things, he told the audience how he had actually been one of the lawmakers who put in place the very law that he ended up suspending. This is back when he was a representative to the Illinois General Assembly.
但我们找到了他在西北大学的一次演讲录音，这是他为数不多地如此个人化、充满情感地谈论这一决定的场合之一。在演讲中，他告诉听众，他本人其实就是制定了最终被他暂停的那部法律的立法者之一。那是他担任伊利诺伊州议会议员时的事情。
In 1977, I voted to reinstate the death penalty in Illinois. I vividly remember an opponent of capital punishment who challenged those of us who voted to put capital punishment back on the book. I was standing on the floor of the House, and I had punched my green button. And somebody on the other side stood up and said, "How many of you that are voting green would be willing to throw the switch in the electric chair?" It was a sobering question and a sobering thought. I don't want to execute anybody, and I don't want to be the executioner. I didn't want to have anything to do with that.
1977年，我投票支持在伊利诺伊州恢复死刑。我清楚地记得，当时有一位死刑反对者质询了我们这些投票支持恢复死刑的人。我当时站在众议院大厅里，按下了我的绿色按钮。对方阵营里有人站起来说：“你们这些投绿色赞成票的人，有谁愿意亲自去拉电椅的开关？”这是一个发人深省的问题，也是一个让人清醒的想法。我不想处决任何人，我也不想成为刽子手。我不想和那件事扯上任何关系。
But he believed in the system, believed it was fair, and he voted for the death penalty. 20 years passed, more than 20 years. Ryan becomes governor. And around the same time, it was becoming clear that there were problems in the way that Illinois was sending men to death row. One case after another was being overturned. And then, the hypothetical question that that legislator had asked back in the 1970s became a very real question for George Ryan. He was the one who had to decide whether the switch would be thrown in the case of a man named Andrew Korkoraleis.
但他相信体制，相信它是公正的，所以他投票支持死刑。20年过去了，20多年过去了。瑞安成了州长。与此同时，很明显伊利诺伊州将人送上死囚牢房的方式存在问题。一个个案件被推翻。然后，那位立法者在70年代提出的假设性问题，对乔治·瑞安来说成了非常现实的问题。他是那个必须决定是否要对一个叫安德鲁·科科拉利斯（Andrew Korkoraleis）的人执行死刑的人。
I began a very extensive review in the case file. I wanted to make sure that there were no mistakes. I called in my trusted friends, both prosecutors and defense lawyers, to have them review the case files. I talked to investigators, and I talked to everybody that I could that had some knowledge about the law. And I agonized, frankly. I'm a pharmacist who had the good fortune to be elected governor of this great state. Now, suddenly, I shouldered the burden of making the decisions about life or death.
我开始对案卷进行非常详尽的审查。我想确保没有任何错误。我召集了我信任的朋友，包括检察官和辩护律师，让他们审阅案卷。我和调查人员谈过，也和所有我能找到的、对法律有所了解的人谈过。坦白说，我感到非常痛苦。我只是一名药剂师，有幸当选为这个伟大州的州长。现在，我突然要承担起决定生死的重任。
Tuesday, March 17th, the day before the execution, Ryan still did not know what to do. At one point, he had his aides type up a stay of execution. At another, he asked for the prayers of Illinois residents. By 7:00 PM, he declared that he was convinced that Korkoraleis was guilty. Six hours later, Korkoraleis was dead. And what comes through in this particular speech is Ryan's anger at having to be the one to decide after so many people along the way had done such a careless job at figuring out guilt in this and other cases. Within a year, he had declared his moratorium.
3月17日星期二，处决的前一天，瑞安仍然不知道该怎么办。有一次，他让助手起草了一份暂缓执行死刑的文件。另一次，他请求伊利诺伊州民众为他祈祷。晚上7点，他宣布他确信科科拉利斯是有罪的。六小时后，科科拉利斯死了。在这次演讲中，瑞安表现出了一种愤怒：在经历了这么多人在处理本案及其他案件时如此草率地判断罪行后，他不得不成为那个做决定的人。一年之内，他宣布了暂停执行死刑的决定。
Get this one. This ought to open everybody's eyes. Nearly half of the 300 capital cases in Illinois have been reversed for a new trial or a re-sentencing. Can you believe that? Almost half out of 300 cases have been rescheduled for re-sentencing or a new trial. It's like flipping a coin, heads or tails, live or die. That's what it's like. Can you believe that?
听听这个。这应该会让所有人大开眼界。伊利诺伊州近300起死刑案件中，近一半被推翻，要求重新审判或重新判刑。你能相信吗？300起案件中几乎有一半被重新排期进行重新判刑或重审。这就像掷硬币，正面还是反面，生还是死。就是这样。你能相信吗？
I've faced my share of criticism over the past three years, and especially from people in my own party, about the moratorium and the clemency hearings. But until you've sat in judgment and made that life or death decision, you really can't debate with me about what it's like to pull the switch. I know the burden, and I know what it feels like to be responsible for a man to be executed. It's not pleasant.
过去三年里，我面临了不少批评，特别是来自我所在党派的人，关于暂停死刑和宽赦听证会。但除非你曾身处审判席，做出过生死攸关的决定，否则你真的无法跟我争论拉动开关是什么感觉。我知道那种重担，也知道对一个人的处决负有责任是什么感觉。这并不好受。
Time passes. People change. Sometimes they change a lot. Today on our program, we bring you three stories about what the passage of time can do to somebody. When each story begins, the world is aligned one way. Then, years pass. Sometimes just months pass, and everything is different. It gives you hope in a way.
时光流逝。人们在改变。有时他们改变得很多。今天我们的节目，为大家带来三个关于时光流逝对人产生影响的故事。当每个故事开始时，世界是按某种方式排列的。然后，几年过去了。有时只是几个月过去了，一切都不同了。这在某种程度上给了你希望。
It's This American Life distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass. Act One of our show today, The Hiker And The Cowman Should Be Friends, Scott Carrier tells the story of how the environmentalists, who ranchers hated the most, who they tried to run out of town on a rail, who they actually hung in effigy, came to take the ranchers' side of things. Act Two, Scrapbook, The Verb, a Houston woman is trying to document every day of her four-year-old daughter's life in preparation for a day faraway. Act Three, Slingshot, John Hodgman tells the story of two people, one beach, one space ride, and what a difference one year makes. Stay with us.
这是由公共广播国际发行的《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。我们今天节目的第一幕，“徒步旅行者和牛仔应该成为朋友”，斯科特·卡里尔讲述了那些牧场主最讨厌的环保主义者——他们曾试图把这些人赶出镇子，甚至给他们扎了稻草人偶来泄愤——是如何转而站在牧场主这一边的。第二幕，“剪贴簿，动词”，一位休斯顿妇女试图记录她四岁女儿生命中的每一天，为遥远的未来做准备。第三幕，“弹弓”，约翰·霍奇曼讲述了两个人的故事，一个海滩，一次太空之旅，以及一年能带来多大的不同。请留下来。
Act One, The Hiker And The Cowman Should Be Friends. Scott Carrier tells this story from southern Utah of a man named Grant Johnson who goes through a huge change over time.
第一幕，“徒步旅行者和牛仔应该成为朋友”。斯科特·卡里尔讲述了这个来自犹他州南部关于一个名叫格兰特·约翰逊的人，随着时间推移经历巨大改变的故事。
The first time I interviewed Grant Johnson he'd just gotten out of jail. He'd been in for eight days, charged with sabotaging four Caterpillar tractors down on the Bird Trail. The Bird Trail was an old dirt road, 60 miles long, connecting Picaboo and Boulder, Utah. It was the middle of nowhere, used mainly by ranchers to graze their cattle on the public lands. The ranchers and the county government wanted to improve the road, turn it into a highway, but a local environmental group was protesting the whole notion. They thought the land should be designated as a wilderness and left alone.
我第一次采访格兰特·约翰逊时，他刚从监狱出来。他被关了八天，罪名是破坏了鸟径（Bird Trail）上的四台卡特彼勒拖拉机。鸟径是一条长60英里的古老土路，连接着犹他州的皮卡布（Picaboo）和博尔德（Boulder）。那里是荒郊野外，主要被牧场主用于在公共土地上放牧牛群。牧场主和县政府想改善这条路，将其变成高速公路，但一个当地的环保组织抗议这一想法。他们认为这片土地应该被指定为荒野，保持原样。
Then, one morning, some of the road workers discovered that someone had poured sand in the gas tanks. And the sheriff arrested Grant Johnson because he was one of the three founding members of the environmental group, which was called SUWA, the Southern Utah Wilderness Alliance. And he lived only a few miles from the scene of the crime. And he'd been such a thorn in their sides, protesting road construction and timber sales, that he'd already been hung in effigy from a lamppost on Main Street in Escalante. When Grant posted bail, the sheriff told him that he couldn't guarantee Grant's safety if he went home.
后来，一天早上，一些筑路工人发现有人往油箱里倒了沙子。警长逮捕了格兰特·约翰逊，因为他是那个环保组织的三位创始人之一，该组织被称为SUWA，即南犹他荒野联盟。他就住在离犯罪现场仅几英里的地方。他一直是他们的眼中钉，抗议修路和木材销售，以至于他已经在埃斯卡兰特（Escalante）主街的灯柱上被扎成了稻草人偶。当格兰特缴纳保释金时，警长告诉他，如果他回家，无法保证他的安全。
So I drove down there to talk to Grant, 250 miles south from Salt Lake to Boulder, then 7 miles east down the bird trail to Deer Creek where I parked and followed the stream until I saw Grant's 16-foot camper trailer. He was living there with his girlfriend, Sue Fearon. Inside was a bed, a little table that folded down, and a gas stove, but no running water, no bathroom, no electricity, no phone. Outside, it was a wilderness, a place of natural forces: red Navajo Sandstone from the Jurassic, dark blue sky, and just real quiet.
所以我开车去那里和格兰特谈话，从盐湖城向南行驶250英里到达博尔德，然后向东沿鸟径行驶7英里到达鹿溪（Deer Creek），我把车停在那儿，沿着小溪走，直到看到格兰特16英尺长的野营拖车。他和女友苏·费伦住在那儿。里面有一张床、一张折叠小桌子和一个煤气炉，但没有自来水，没有厕所，没有电，没有电话。外面是荒野，一个自然力量主导的地方：侏罗纪时代的红色纳瓦霍砂岩，深蓝色的天空，非常安静。
Well, my name is Grant Johnson. I live at Deer Creek Ranch. I've been in the area of southern Utah, mainly around the Bird Trail, since '75. I've lived on either end of the Bird Trail or on it. And I first came here when I was 16, and it was just incredibly beautiful. That's the number one thing about this country is it's just so beautiful you drop your jaw, you know? There's nothing like it anywhere. From here, I could get on a horse and ride for 80 miles before I'd hit Lake Powell and not see anyone or any sign of man. There's just one road here to cross, and then there wouldn't be another road. So you feel like you're seeing a lot of it for the first time, the first white man, you know? You have the feeling of the first white man a lot. And it's a real sense of freedom too. There's no people, no law. It just feels real free, wide open.
嗯，我叫格兰特·约翰逊。我住在鹿溪牧场。自1975年以来，我一直待在犹他州南部地区，主要是鸟径附近。我住过鸟径的任何一端，或者干脆就住在路上。我第一次来这里时只有16岁，这里简直美得惊人。这就是这个地方最棒的一点，它美得让你目瞪口呆，你知道吗？世界上没有别的地方像这样。从这里，我可以骑马走上80英里直到鲍威尔湖，而不遇见任何人或看到任何人类活动的迹象。这里只有一条路要穿过，然后就再也不会有其他路了。所以你会觉得自己像是一个白人，第一次见到这么多原始景象。你常常会有那种“第一位白人”的感觉。这也是一种真正的自由感。没有人群，没有法律。感觉真的很自由，广阔无垠。
I never asked Grant if he sabotaged the equipment, I think mainly because I didn't want to see him lie. It was like a little war back then, a turf battle between the cowboys and the environmentalists, Heavenly Father versus Mother Earth. Both sides considered the land to be sacred. So maybe it was more like a holy war, a clash of cultures.
我从未问过格兰特他是否破坏了设备，我想主要是因为我不想看着他说谎。那就像是一场小规模的战争，牛仔和环保主义者之间的地盘之争，天父与大地母亲。双方都认为土地是神圣的。所以也许这更像是一场圣战，一种文化的碰撞。
This is Boulder cattleman Dell LeFevre, also back in '87, a man who works from sunup to sundown, who wouldn't even stop his chores during the interview.
这是博尔德的牧牛人戴尔·勒费弗尔，同样是在1987年，一个从日出干到日落，连采访期间都不肯停下手头活计的人。
Yeah, we're the steward of the land. The Lord give us this land to take of it. And I think if we don't take care of this land, we're going to answer in the hereafter. And the do-gooders, as I call them-- some call them the tree-huggers-- the do-gooders come along and, really, what purpose do they have? What stake have they got in this ground? They've got a job in Salt Lake, a job in Denver, a job in Flagstaff.
是的，我们是土地的守护者。上帝把这片土地交给我们来照料。我认为如果我们不爱护这片土地，我们在来世会遭到审判。而那些所谓的好心人——有些人叫他们“抱树者”——这些好心人来了，他们到底有什么目的？他们在这片土地上有什么利益？他们在盐湖城有工作，在丹佛有工作，在弗拉格斯塔夫有工作。
My thing is I don't think the ranchers has hurt this land in the last 88, 90 years they've been here. I mean, let's say we turn this all over to the environmentalists, you know? Shut her down. They want this road shut down, let's just shut the road down. Let's just let it go back to natural. How many people would see this? How many people'd enjoy it?
我觉得在过去88、90年里，牧场主并没有破坏这片土地。我的意思是，假设我们把这一切都交给环保主义者，你知道？关闭它。他们想关闭这条路，那就关掉吧。让它回归自然。有多少人能看到这个？有多少人会享受它？
They backpack on the trails that we've carved out. They backpack on our cow trails, the hikers, you know? If we didn't have them trails there, they wouldn't even get there. And my question, I guess, to everybody, what would Boulder be without a ranch? Do you think Boulder'd be Boulder without boulders? They're losing who really take care of the land. They don't take care of the land. All they want to do is come out and smoke their pot, do their little hiking around, and go home.
他们在我们开辟的小路上背包旅行。徒步旅行者在我们的牛道上背包旅行，你知道吗？如果我们没有那些小路，他们甚至根本到不了那里。我想我得问大家一个问题，没有牧场的博尔德会是什么样？你觉得没有岩石的博尔德还能叫博尔德吗？他们失去了真正照料土地的人。他们不照料土地。他们只想出来抽大麻，随便远足一下，然后回家。
The holy war was about a number of things: road construction, timber sales, energy development, mining rights. But part of the holy war was simply about cows, cows grazing on the public land. There's a lot of public land in southern Utah, about 90% of it. And even though it's mostly sand, and sandstone, and sagebrush, there's still enough grass and other plants along the river banks and up in the mountains for cows to feed. And when the Mormon pioneers first settled the land, that's how they survived, by running their cattle over huge areas.
圣战涉及很多事情：道路建设、木材销售、能源开发、采矿权。但圣战的一部分仅仅是关于牛，牛在公共土地上吃草。犹他州南部有很多公共土地，约占90%。尽管那里主要是沙地、砂岩和鼠尾草丛，但在河岸和山上仍然有足够的草和其他植物供牛进食。当摩门教先驱第一次定居这片土地时，他们就是通过在大片区域放牧牛群来生存的。
The problem was that the ranchers sometimes put too many cows out there. And then they sometimes left the cows alone for long periods of time, and the cows overgrazed causing some serious erosion and environmental destruction. So the environmentalists wanted the cows out of there. They were destructive, and they were not native to the desert. And they also left cow pies everywhere they went, cow dung, not the tidy, little berries left by deer, but big, sloppy glops of poop on the trails and in the rivers. And a lot of backpackers felt this detracted from their wilderness experience. So for the environmentalists, the cow pies became a symbol of everything wrong with the management of the public land. But for the ranchers, Grant Johnson was the symbol of everything wrong with the environmentalists.
问题在于，牧场主有时放牧的牛太多了。而且他们有时会把牛单独留在那里很长时间，牛群过度放牧导致了一些严重的侵蚀和环境破坏。所以环保主义者想把牛赶出去。它们具有破坏性，而且不是沙漠原生物种。它们走到哪里还留下牛粪，不是鹿留下的那种整洁的小圆珠，而是大块大块、粘糊糊的粪便，在小径上和河流中。许多背包客觉得这破坏了他们的荒野体验。所以对于环保主义者来说，牛粪成了公共土地管理一切不当的象征。但对于牧场主来说，格兰特·约翰逊是环保主义者一切不当的象征。
I didn't really realize it. Maybe I'm kind of thick-skinned, but I didn't really realize how clear the divisions were in town, environmentalists or hippie. I didn't realize a lot of things. I didn't realize how under people's skin Grant had gotten. There were people that just absolutely hated him. I mean, he was in their midst, and he didn't appear to be leaving.
我没太意识到。也许我脸皮厚，但我没意识到镇上的分歧有多么清晰，环保主义者还是嬉皮士。我没意识到很多事情。我没意识到格兰特已经让人多么反感。有些人简直恨透了他。我的意思是，他就在他们中间，而且似乎不打算离开。
That's Sue Fearon, Grant's girlfriend. They're married now, but back then, she was still pretty much a young woman from the coast of Connecticut. She met Grant after she got out of college when she had a summer job as a ranger in Zion National Park. Grant told Sue about the land he owned on Deer Creek, and that he had some horses, and was going to get some more, and start an outfitting company taking tourists down into the canyon country to these beautiful places he'd discovered. Sue thought Grant was a man with a plan. And she went with him to Deer Creek one night under a full moon and, basically, never left. That was before Grant got arrested. She didn't really realize she was walking into a war zone.
那是苏·费伦，格兰特的女友。他们现在已经结婚了，但那时，她还是个来自康涅狄格州海岸的年轻女子。她大学毕业后做了一份暑期工作，在锡安国家公园担任护林员，之后认识了格兰特。格兰特告诉苏他在鹿溪拥有的土地，说他有一些马，还打算再买一些，开一家野外向导公司，带着游客到他发现的这些美丽的峡谷地区。苏认为格兰特是个有计划的人。于是有一天晚上，在满月下，她跟着他去了鹿溪，基本上就再也没离开过。那是在格兰特被捕之前。她并没有真正意识到自己正走进一个战区。
Nine felonies and four misdemeanors, and he was thrown in jail. And they set his bail at $250,000, which was-- I mean, there was a guy in there who had shot somebody through the head, and his bail was $50,000. But, at any rate, nonetheless, we raised $260,000 in property.
九项重罪和四项轻罪，他被关进了监狱。他们把保释金定在25万美元，这——我的意思是，里面有个开枪射中别人头部的人，他的保释金才5万美元。但无论如何，尽管如此，我们还是凑齐了26万美元的财产。
It was pretty interesting. The county attorney tried to make it a condition of bail that he'd not return to his home until the whole matter was settled, which is absolutely unheard of. He represented the environmental community. And I think there were forces here, elected officials, who thought if he went away, if we could uproot him and get him out of Deer Creek, we would be done with this.
这挺有意思的。县检察官试图把“不得回家直到事情解决”作为保释条件，这绝对是闻所未闻的。他代表了环保群体。而且我认为这里有力量，有民选官员认为，如果他离开了，如果我们能把他连根拔起并让他离开鹿溪，我们就能摆脱这一切了。
Fortunately, we are absolutely blessed by having two very good friends who are lawyers. We don't have a lot of money. And if he had had to go with the public defender, he would have been traded over breakfast at the Flying J in Panguitch. They would have cut a deal, and that would be that.
幸运的是，我们非常幸运地拥有两位非常有本事的朋友，他们是律师。我们没有多少钱。如果他不得不找公设辩护人，他早就在潘圭奇（Panguitch）的Flying J餐厅吃早餐时被交易出去了。他们会达成交易，事情也就那样了。
For two years, everyone held their breath. That's how long it took for Grant to go to trial. And then, it turned into kind of a farce. The county just didn't have any evidence, and they dropped the charges.
两年来，每个人都屏住呼吸。格兰特等待审判的时间就是那么长。然后，它变成了一场闹剧。县里根本没有任何证据，他们撤销了指控。
Somebody, a friend of ours, took us aside and said, "You guys should go away for a while. Things are really hot. They're talking it up in Escalante. They want to come and route you out." And I said, "You know, we'll lock the gate, but we're not going anywhere."
有人，我们的一个朋友，把我们拉到一边说：“你们应该离开一阵子。情况真的很火爆。他们在埃斯卡兰特到处议论。他们想过来把你们赶走。”我说：“你知道，我们会锁上大门，但我们哪儿也不去。”
And the first thing we did was we went to Salt Lake City, and we went to my favorite gun store. And I pointed out all the guns that I needed to buy and all the little clips that I needed to go with them. And I came back with, I guess maybe, defensive weapons.
我们做的第一件事就是去了盐湖城，去了我最喜欢的枪店。我指出了我需要购买的所有枪支以及随之配套的所有小弹夹。我回来时，我想也许带着防御性武器吧。
What did you buy?
你买了什么？
A Mini-14 with a 40-round clip. It's a semi-automatic and--
一把Mini-14，配40发弹夹。那是半自动步枪，而且——
Pistol or a rifle?
手枪还是步枪？
That's a rifle. And then a 38.
那是步枪。还有一把38口径手枪。
Grant and Sue pretty much kept to themselves, staying out on Deer Creek, working on their land, raising horses, and getting ready to start their outfitting company. It must have been tough living alone in the middle of nowhere, no power, no phone, on the edge of a community of 100 people, some of whom hated their guts. One day, Sue went to pick up Grant's kids from his first marriage.
格兰特和苏基本上与世隔绝，待在鹿溪，经营他们的土地，养马，准备开始他们的野外向导业务。独自住在荒郊野外一定很难，没有电，没有电话，处于一个100人社区的边缘，其中一些人恨死他们了。有一天，苏去接格兰特第一次婚姻留下的孩子们。
So anyhow, as I was approaching Escalante, a fellow who worked for the county in a county dump truck was coming towards me, and he ran me off the road while flipping me off. What a talent, huh? One hand running me off the road, and I ended up in the ditch. But at any rate, this is, you know--
总之，当我接近埃斯卡兰特时，一个在县里开自卸卡车的家伙正朝我开过来，他一边对我竖中指，一边把我挤出了路面。真是天才，对吧？一只手把我挤出路面，最后我掉进了沟里。但无论如何，这就是，你知道——
So anyhow, I go to Cedar City, or Paragonah, and I pick up the kids, and I come back. And when I got back-- now we've got kids around, so we don't want to leave the gun loaded-- I dropped the bullets out of it. It's a revolver, and I dropped the bullets out on the dash and left the gun there.
总之，我去了锡达城或帕拉戈纳（Paragonah），接到了孩子们，然后回来。当我回来的时候——现在有孩子在身边，所以我们不想把枪装上子弹——我把子弹退了出来。那是把左轮手枪，我把子弹掉在仪表盘上，就把枪留在那儿了。
Well, the next morning, Grant and I are sitting and we're having coffee. And the gate's locked down at the bottom of the ranch. And we look out the window, and here come two or three guys riding on horseback with long things laid across their legs in front of their saddle. And I thought holy mother of God, we're going to be killed, and we haven't even had coffee. So I go flying out of the house, ripped the door open, and started stuffing bullets. And I get three in there, and think, good enough, and slam it shut, and turn around.
第二天早上，我和格兰特坐在那儿喝咖啡。牧场底部的大门锁着。我们看向窗外，这时来了两三个人骑着马，鞍前横放着长长的东西。我想天哪，我们要被杀了，我们连咖啡都没喝呢。所以我冲出屋子，猛地拉开门，开始往枪里塞子弹。我塞进去三发，觉得够了，猛地合上，转过身去。
And the guy's right behind me, and he's grinning from ear to ear. And he sees that I have flown out of the house and have grabbed a gun. And I've got a gun right in my hands. It's not pointing at him. It's pointing down on the ground. And he's smiling at me. And I think, well, something's not right. And he goes, "Hi, ma'am. We're with the cougar study. We'd just like permission to come through." And my knees were knocking together under my bathrobe. And Grant comes flying out with his 22. And I say, "Oh honey, they're here for the cougar study."
那个人就在我身后，咧着嘴笑。他看到我从屋里飞奔出来，抓起了一把枪。我的手里确实拿着枪。它没有指着他，而是对着地面。他正对着我笑。我想，好吧，有些事不太对劲。他说：“嗨，女士。我们是美洲狮研究小组的。想请你准许我们穿过这里。”我的膝盖在睡袍下直打颤。格兰特拿着他的22口径步枪飞奔出来。我说：“哦，亲爱的，他们是来做美洲狮研究的。”
Again, this all happened in the 1980's. When Grant was arrested, Reagan was in the White House. Then Bush came and went. When Clinton was elected, the environmental movement gained a lot of momentum. By 1995, Sue had helped write a proposal to Congress to designate 5.7 million acres of southern Utah as wilderness areas. So I went back to Deer Creek to interview Grant again, but I was stunned at the man who'd been the living embodiment of the environmental movement, a man who'd risked everything for it, was now talking just like the cowboys.
再说一次，这都发生在80年代。格兰特被捕时，里根在白宫。然后布什来了又走。克林顿当选时，环保运动声势大振。到1995年，苏已经帮助写了一份提交给国会的提案，将犹他州南部570万英亩的土地指定为荒野地区。所以我回到鹿溪再次采访格兰特，但我惊呆了，那个曾经是环保运动活生生的化身、为之孤注一掷的人，现在说起话来简直和牛仔一模一样。
Personally, I think the worst threat we have is the threat of a national park happening over here. The national park trend is to develop, build roads, hire as many police as they can, which are rangers, and then bust people for breaking the rules.
就我个人而言，我认为我们面临的最严重威胁是这里要建立国家公园的威胁。国家公园的趋势是开发、修路、雇佣尽可能多的警察——也就是护林员，然后因为人们打破规则而逮捕他们。
That was Grant. Sue felt pretty much the same way. She'd had enough of the environmentalists.
那是格兰特。苏的感觉也差不多。她受够了环保主义者。
They're shrill. They're shrill. They're insensitive, and they're shrill. And they have no empathy. And they have, I think, perhaps, a limited understanding of what's going on down here.
他们很尖锐。他们很刺耳。他们麻木不仁，而且很刺耳。他们没有同理心。而且我认为，也许他们对这里正在发生的事情了解有限。
In the years that had passed, SUWA has evolved from a grassroots organization of three guys around a kitchen table into an established, urban corporation with lawyers and lobbyists in Washington and a long list of donating members from all over the country and even Europe. SUWA had also kicked Grant off its board of directors because they no longer saw eye to eye. Grant had switched sides right in the middle of a heated political battle, something that almost never happens. And he'd done in the rarest of ways, by looking at the evidence and then concluding he'd been dead wrong. It had been a war about cows, and he decided cows weren't that bad.
在过去的几年里，SUWA已经从一张厨房桌子周围三个人的草根组织，演变成一个成熟的城市公司，在华盛顿有律师和说唱客，还有来自全国乃至欧洲的长长的捐款会员名单。SUWA还将格兰特踢出了董事会，因为他们不再志同道合。格兰特在一场激烈的政治斗争中倒戈了，这种情况几乎从未发生过。而且他以最罕见的方式做到了：观察证据，然后得出结论——他之前错得离谱。这是一场关于牛的战争，他认为牛并没有那么糟糕。
When you first came here, you didn't like cows?
你刚来这里的时候，不喜欢牛？
No, I hated cows. I still don't like cows. It's just I have honestly seen that cows do not hurt the land here. In 22 years of exploring this country, I've seen where the cows are, where they aren't, where they used to be and aren't anymore, where they didn't used to be and are now. And the places that the cows do get don't look much different than the places that they can't get.
不，我讨厌牛。我还是不喜欢牛。只是我诚实地看到，这里的牛并没有伤害土地。在探索这片土地的22年里，我看到了牛在哪里，它们不在哪里，它们曾经在哪里但现在不在了，它们以前不在但现在在了。牛能去的地方，看起来和它们去不了的地方没什么两样。
And I'm not saying this is true for Great Basin, or Arizona, or Idaho, or anywhere else. But here, in the Escalante, in these canyons, I think the grazing doesn't hurt anything. A canyon bottom, like the gulch, they trail cows through there. And I've seen people, campers, in there. And they see these cows go through, and pound up the ground, and crap everywhere. And then the campers scream about the cows, say how horrible they are. The campers go back to the city. And a month later, I go back down to the same canyon, and you can't tell there was ever a cow in it. It's grown up with grass and clover.
我并不是说这在大盆地、亚利桑那州、爱达荷州或其他任何地方都适用。但在这里，在埃斯卡兰特，在这些峡谷里，我认为放牧不会伤害任何东西。峡谷底部，像峡谷沟壑，他们把牛赶过那里。我见过露营者在那里。他们看到牛穿过，把地踏平，到处拉屎。然后露营者就对着牛尖叫，说它们有多糟糕。露营者回到城里。一个月后，我回到同一个峡谷，你根本看不出里面有过牛。它已经长满了草和三叶草。
And down on the river bottom, there was a place where the gulch hit the river where you couldn't walk through there because the guy hadn't put cows in there in so many years. Well, he finally started putting his cows down there, and now it's much grassier. You can hike through it, and, in my opinion, it's a lot more pleasant. And so I'm not really sure that what's being blamed on cows is really their fault.
在河底，峡谷汇入河流的地方曾经有一个地方，你没法走过去，因为那个人很多年没在那儿放过牛了。好吧，他终于开始把牛赶到那里了，现在那里草多多了。你可以徒步穿过它，在我看来，它更令人愉快。所以我不太确定那些被归咎于牛的问题真的是它们的错。
In Grant's mind, he was still an environmentalist because he continued to be deeply in love with the wilderness around him. In fact, he remained a member of SUWA and sent them checks because he thought they were a necessary force in defending and promoting wilderness areas. But he'd become like a devout Christian who no longer went to church because he just couldn't get along with the other members. When I asked Sue about it, how the change came about, she told me it started when she made friends with an old rancher in Boulder, Kirk Lyman.
在格兰特心目中，他仍然是个环保主义者，因为他继续深深地爱着他周围的荒野。事实上，他仍然是SUWA的会员，并给他们寄支票，因为他认为他们是捍卫和促进荒野地区的必要力量。但他变得像一个不再去教堂的虔诚基督徒，因为他无法与其他成员相处。当我问苏关于这件事时，改变是如何发生的，她告诉我是从她和博尔德的一位老牧场主柯克·莱曼（Kirk Lyman）交朋友开始的。
Kirk was probably almost 40 years my senior, about my dad's age. And one day, I was at the Bird Trail Grill and he said he was getting all these magazines, and did I need something to read. The bookmobile came every once in a while, but, pretty much, we passed magazines around a lot. So he said he had all these magazines. And I thought, huh. I didn't even know he spoke. I'd seen him around town. And I figured that he was opening a door.
柯克比我大快40岁，和我爸爸差不多年纪。有一天，我在鸟径烧烤店，他说他订了好多杂志，问我需不需要读点什么。流动图书馆偶尔会来，但基本上，我们经常互相传阅杂志。所以他说他有所有这些杂志。我想，哈。我甚至不知道他会开口说话。我常在镇上见到他。我以为他在打开一扇门。
When Sue told me this, things became instantly more clear. Sue is pretty, and funny, and good with horses. Of course, the cowboys wanted to talk to her.
当苏告诉我这件事时，事情瞬间变得清晰起来。苏漂亮、有趣，擅长骑马。当然，牛仔们想和她交谈。
So anyway, I just kind of got in the habit of visiting with him and hanging out with him. And maybe he had a project to do, and I'd help him with it. And then we were raising some horses here, and he'd come down. And I'd make biscuits and coffee for Sunday breakfast. And Kirk was bossy. Kirk once told me how to strike a match. I am not kidding you. I couldn't make that up if I wanted to. He definitely told you how to do it.
总之，我就养成了去拜访他、和他待在一起的习惯。也许他有什么活儿要干，我会帮他。然后我们在养一些马，他会过来。我会为周日的早餐做饼干和咖啡。柯克爱指挥人。柯克有次教我怎么划火柴。我没开玩笑。如果我想编故事也编不出这个。他绝对是那种会告诉你该怎么做的人。
Kirk took Sue riding with him up on Boulder Mountain packing salt for the Cattlemen's Association. And he told her stories, cowboy stories, like how, when he was a kid, he'd go out to the Circle Cliffs, and rope wild horses, and take them home and break them. One time, he had a wild horse that no one could ride. It wouldn't be broken. And eventually, it ran straight into the corral and broke its neck.
柯克带着苏骑马去博尔德山为牧牛人协会运送盐。他给她讲故事，牛仔故事，比如他小时候怎么去圆崖（Circle Cliffs），套野马，带回家驯服它们。有一次，他有一匹没人能骑的野马。它驯服不了。最终，它直接冲进围栏，摔断了脖子。
And I said, "Well, what'd you do?" And he said, "Well, we went down to the Circle Cliffs and got another one." And that was kind of his attitude. It was a very utilitarian approach, I guess some people would say kind of un-enlightened. You know? What about the rights of that horse? What would PETA say about that? I don't know. They wouldn't like it.
我说：“好吧，那你怎么办？”他说：“嗯，我们就下到圆崖又抓了一匹。”这就是他的态度。这是一个非常实用的方法，我想有些人会说这有点愚昧。你知道吗？那匹马的权利呢？善待动物组织（PETA）会怎么说？我不知道。他们不会喜欢的。
So anyway, I guess I always have had this ability to listen to Kirk, his conversation, and to hear it, to live it, to understand what he was doing, to picture running full-bore on a horse in wild country trying to rope another horse. And then the other part of me is saying, what would PETA think? You know?
总之，我想我一直有这种倾听柯克谈话的能力，去听，去感受，去理解他在做什么，去想象在野外骑马全速奔跑试图套住另一匹马的场景。然后我的另一面在说，PETA会怎么想？你知道吗？
So Sue became friends with Kirk. And since Kirk had lived in Boulder most of his life and was well respected in the community, she automatically became friends with other locals. Grant was right behind her realizing that the cowboys, or at least some of the cowboys, were pretty good guys after all.
所以苏和柯克成了朋友。由于柯克一生大部分时间都住在博尔德，在社区里很受尊重，她自动地和其他当地人成了朋友。格兰特紧随其后，意识到牛仔们，或者至少部分牛仔们，毕竟都是挺不错的人。
Like, here's an example. One time I was riding out for a week by myself, and I had a pack horse. And I got to where one canyon joined another. And I looked upstream, and there were these bright, orange tents sitting in the flood plain right in the middle of the trail, and they looked like UFOs.
比如，举个例子。有一次我独自骑马出去一周，带了一匹驮马。我到了一个峡谷与另一个峡谷交汇的地方。我向河流上游看去，那里有闪亮的橙色帐篷坐在洪泛区，就在小径中间，看起来像UFO一样。
I turned right, went a quarter mile, and I ran into a herd of cows. And behind the herd of cows was this old-timer, Ivan Lyman, and his son. And his son had no shirt on, and had about a 10-foot long willow that he was herding the cows with, and a big grin on his face. And Ivan was smiling and sitting on his horse. And I stopped. And he stopped and said, "How's it going?" And he was just part of the land. I could just see it. His face looked like the cliffs looked. And the cows, and his horse, and his saddle were all the color of the dirt. They were just a part of the land.
我向右转，走了四分之一英里，撞见了一群牛。在牛群后面是那位老伙计，伊万·莱曼（Ivan Lyman）和他的儿子。他儿子没穿衬衫，手里拿着一根10英尺长的柳条赶牛，脸上挂着灿烂的笑容。伊万正微笑着坐在他的马上。我停了下来。他也停下来说：“怎么样？”他简直就是土地的一部分。我一眼就能看出来。他的脸看起来就像那些悬崖。牛群、他的马和他的马鞍都是泥土的颜色。他们就是土地的一部分。
Given the choice of who he identified with, it definitely wasn't the people in the orange tents. The cowboys had done everything they could to threaten and intimidate Grant and Sue, but they'd stayed because their love of the land was stronger than the fear of the locals. And because they'd stayed, they ended up siding with the cowboys. Both Grant, and Sue, and the cowboys came to realize that they shared the common experience of living and surviving in the wilderness, which was both very difficult and very rewarding.
给他选择他认同的人，那绝对不是橙色帐篷里的那些人。牛仔们曾竭尽全力威胁和恐吓格兰特和苏，但他们留了下来，因为他们对土地的热爱超过了对当地人的恐惧。正因为他们留了下来，他们最终站在了牛仔这一边。格兰特、苏和牛仔们都意识到，他们有着在荒野中生活和生存的共同经历，这既非常困难，又非常有成就感。
Now, these days, Grant and Sue are busy with their outfitting company, Escalante Canyon Outfitters, taking tourists into remote areas of the desert. Most of their business comes from people returning for a second and third trip. They have seven horses in a big, circular corral. They keep their land irrigated and green with alfalfa.
如今，格兰特和苏忙于他们的野外向导公司，埃斯卡兰特峡谷向导公司（Escalante Canyon Outfitters），带着游客进入沙漠的偏远地区。他们大部分生意来自第二次和第三次光顾的游客。他们在巨大的圆形围栏里养了七匹马。他们用紫花苜蓿让土地保持灌溉和绿色。
Grant is carving out a new house from a sandstone mound next to their camper trailer. The mound is 60 feet tall and 150 feet wide, a huge dome. And they have a six-year-old daughter, Claire, who reminds me of a little mountain goat, white, translucent hair. She sits up on the side of the dome looking down at you in silence. Their place looks good, even beautiful. They're living their dream.
格兰特正在他们的野营拖车旁的一座砂岩堆里凿出一栋新房子。土堆有60英尺高，150英尺宽，是一个巨大的圆顶。他们有一个六岁的女儿克莱尔，让我想起了一只小山羊，有着白色、半透明的头发。她坐在圆顶的一侧，静静地向下看着你。他们的地方看起来很棒，甚至很美。他们正在过着自己的梦想生活。
The last time I was down there I drove around Boulder looking for Dell LeFevre, the cattleman I'd interviewed back in '87. He's still there, still running cows.
我最后一次去那里时，我在博尔德到处寻找戴尔·勒费弗尔，就是我在87年采访过的那个牧牛人。他还在那儿，还在放牛。
Do you remember the first time you met Sue?
你还记得第一次见到苏的情景吗？
First time I ever seen Sue, she just looked like a little hippie chick to me. And see, my war go way back with hippies. So I'm not a hippie lover. And man, I see her around with Grant. And Grant and I've kind of been on opposite sides for years because he was all wilderness and I was multiple use. And Grant's had a struggle around here. You've got to give it to old Grant. Grant, he wasn't very well liked around here because of his beliefs. Hell, I'd have packed up and left a long time ago if people treated me like they was treating old Grant. But Grant stuck it out. Grant stayed right with it.
我第一次见到苏，她在我眼里就像个小嬉皮士。你看，我和嬉皮士的战争由来已久。所以我不是嬉皮士爱好者。伙计，我看到她和格兰特在一起。多年来我和格兰特一直立场对立，因为他全是荒野，而我是多用途使用。格兰特在这里斗争过。你不得不佩服老格兰特。格兰特，因为他的信仰，在这里不太受欢迎。该死，如果人们像对待老格兰特那样对待我，我早就收拾行李走人了。但格兰特坚持了下来。格兰特一直坚持着。
And they don't bother anybody. They do their work. They do their thing. And Grant and Sue, they fit in my class now. They're working people. I love working people. Anybody can start a business and make it. That's my kind of people. I can forgive anybody of anything if they're hard workers.
而且他们不打扰任何人。他们做自己的工作。他们做自己的事。格兰特和苏，现在属于我这一类人了。他们是劳动人民。我爱劳动人民。任何能创业并成功的人。那才是我这种人。如果他们是努力工作的人，我可以原谅任何人做过的任何事。
So you've changed too, you think?
所以你也变了，你觉得吗？
You have to change. You change. Life can't go on. I mean, look how Boulder's changed. You have to change with the times. You can't put a door up and say hey, if you're not a cowboy, don't come to Boulder.
你必须改变。你改变。生活不能一成不变。我是说，看看博尔德是怎么变的。你必须随时代而变。你不能竖起一扇门说，嘿，如果你不是牛仔，就别来博尔德。
When Grant moved to Boulder in 1975, there were 30 ranchers and 100 people in town. Now there are 5 ranchers and 200 people, only 12 of whom have been there longer than Grant. Over the years, SUWA and other environmental groups succeeded in getting the government agencies to watch and regulate cattle on public land way more aggressively.
格兰特1975年搬到博尔德时，镇上有30个牧场主，100人。现在有5个牧场主，200人，其中只有12人比格兰特来得更早。多年来，SUWA和其他环保组织成功地使政府机构更加积极地监督和管理公共土地上的牛群。
The cattlemen, of course, would like to be left alone. But, at the same time, they admit that mistakes were made in the past. It's never been easy to graze cows in a desert. And now they've got these regulations and the competition from more efficient corporate ranches in Florida. And on top of all this, for the past five years, there's been a severe drought in southern Utah. So they're going out of business, and the environmentalists are at least a part of the reason why.
牧牛人当然希望不被打扰。但同时，他们承认过去确实犯过错误。在沙漠里放牛从来都不容易。现在他们有了这些法规，还要面对佛罗里达州效率更高的企业牧场的竞争。再加上过去五年里，犹他州南部一直遭遇严重干旱。所以他们正在破产，而环保主义者至少是原因之一。
SUWA's a bad bunch, as far as ranchers are concerned. They want cows off. That's their goal. There was "Cows Free '93," "No Moo." I forget all their little slogans. But they've wanted cows off the public land now for ever since they started, 20, 25 years ago. In fact, Grant was probably one of the fathers of that. That was their goal, and they've done a good job. You try to do something, and they appeal it. I try to put a water tank in, and they'll appeal it. It's a tough thing when they get so much clout. Everything you do, they appeal. They can stop anything.
就牧场主而言，SUWA是个坏家伙。他们想把牛赶走。那是他们的目标。曾经有“93年无牛”、“禁止哞哞”。我忘了他们所有的那些小口号了。但从他们开始后的20、25年来，他们一直想把牛赶出公共土地。事实上，格兰特可能还是其中的鼻祖之一。那是他们的目标，他们干得很好。你试图做点什么，他们就上诉。我试着建个储水罐，他们就上诉。当他们有这么大的影响力时，事情就很难办了。你做的每一件事，他们都上诉。他们能阻止任何事情。
And Boulder has been ruined. These big ranches down in that valley, they're gone. Ranching's done, let's face it. The environmental groups won. Do you want to see this valley in 5-acre lots and little houses? Is that what they wanted? A Sedona? Park City? Well, they got her. You come by here when my bunch is gone, and you'll see nothing but houses here.
博尔德已经被毁了。山谷里的那些大牧场，都没了。放牧完了，面对现实吧。环保组织赢了。你想看到这个山谷变成5英亩一块的房产和一栋栋小房子吗？这就是他们想要的吗？一个塞多纳？帕克城？好吧，他们得偿所愿了。等我这一拨人走后你再来，除了房子你什么都看不到。
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
[交叉声音]
When I was down there that last time, I went to a party Grant and Sue threw for some friends who were moving to Montana because they have kids and the local school in Boulder is not so good. There were about 100 people, mostly families from Boulder, lots of kids, everybody outside by the dome and trailer under a full moon, a beautiful night. Sue invited a couple of local ranchers, but they didn't show up, maybe because of the beer and alcohol-- they're Mormons-- or maybe because they just wouldn't have felt comfortable around so many newcomers to the area.
我最后一次去那儿时，参加了一个格兰特和苏为几位搬去蒙大拿的朋友举办的聚会，因为他们有孩子，而博尔德当地的学校不太好。大约有100人，大多是来自博尔德的家庭，有很多孩子，大家在满月下的圆顶和拖车外，一个美好的夜晚。苏邀请了几个当地牧场主，但他们没来，可能是因为啤酒和酒精——他们是摩门教徒——也可能是因为他们在镇上这么多新面孔周围会感到不自在。
It's kind of tragic. The ranchers are nearly gone, and people are moving in from the cities, which is pretty much how it's going all over the West. It's possible that the people moving in will come to see and appreciate the land in the way Grant and Sue have, that they'll eventually share the common experience of living in this beautiful place. But there won't be any cowboys around to help them.
这有点悲剧。牧场主几乎绝迹了，人们从城市搬进来，这基本上就是整个西部正在发生的事情。搬进来的人有可能像格兰特和苏那样看待和欣赏这片土地，他们最终会分享在这片美丽地方生活的共同经历。但周围不会有任何牛仔来帮助他们。
Scott Carrier. His stories are funded partly by hearingvoices.com and the Corporation for Public Broadcasting.
斯科特·卡里尔。他的故事部分由hearingvoices.com和公共广播公司资助。
[MUSIC - "THE HIKER AND THE COWMAN" BY JON LANGFORD AND JOHN RAUHAUS]
[音乐 - 乔恩·兰福德和约翰·劳豪斯的《徒步旅行者和牛仔》]
Well, yeehaw, Jon Langford with John Rauhaus with apologies to Rodgers and Hammerstein. Coming up, the slingshot killed Goliath but not John Hodgman. Details in a minute from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International, when our program continues.
好吧，唷呼，乔恩·兰福德与约翰·劳豪斯，向罗杰斯和汉默斯坦道歉。接下来，弹弓杀死了歌利亚，但没杀死约翰·霍奇曼。稍后从芝加哥公共广播电台和公共广播国际带来详细报道，我们的节目继续。
Act Two, Scrapbook, The Verb. If you don't know it already, there's a whole scrapbooking thing going on in this country: scrapbook stores, scrapbook seminars, scrapbook conventions, and magazines. They have made scrapbook into a verb, as in, "Not now, I'm scrapbooking."
第二幕，“剪贴簿，动词”。如果你还不知道，这个国家正在流行一种剪贴簿潮流：剪贴簿商店、剪贴簿研讨会、剪贴簿大会和杂志。他们把剪贴簿变成了一个动词，比如：“现在不行，我正在做剪贴簿（scrapbooking）。”
Kim Meyer and Julie Checkoway spent some time living in that world to put together a documentary. And along the way, they met one woman whose scrapbooking was so intense that it took on a special kind of character. In her suburban Houston home, where other people would have the dining room, she has a room that's filled with hundreds of ink stamps, thousands of stickers, countless sheets of pattern papers, scrapbook supplies, all ready for a launch toward a future years from now. Kim Meyer tells the story.
金·迈耶和朱莉·切科韦在那个世界里生活了一段时间，制作了一部纪录片。在此过程中，他们遇到了一位女士，她的剪贴簿做得非常极致，以至于它呈现出一种特殊的性格。在她位于休斯顿郊区的家中，别人放餐厅的地方，她有一间堆满了数百个印章、数千张贴纸、无数图案纸张和剪贴簿用品的房间，一切准备就绪，只为向多年后的未来发射。金·迈耶讲述了这个故事。
Timi Emmons keeps her scrapbooks by the window so in case of fire, she can break the glass from the outside and rescue them. Timi is in her late 30s, blond hair, the sort of woman who doesn't like to answer the door without her makeup on. Pretty much every single scrapbook she's made is of her daughter, Maddie.
蒂米·埃蒙斯把她的剪贴簿放在窗边，这样万一发生火灾，她可以从外面打碎玻璃把它们救出来。蒂米快40岁了，金发，那种不化妆就不愿意开门的女性。她做的几乎每一本剪贴簿都是关于她女儿麦迪（Maddie）的。
7, 8, 9, 10, 11, and then, not in books, this is probably 12, 13. I think I have 3 more, so I probably have 15 or 16. I have 15 or 16 albums, and I've only, probably, touched the last three years. Her first year of life I haven't even touched yet. You know, she's four years old and already has 17 books. I'm going to have to start my own library.
7、8、9、10、11，然后，不在书里的，这可能是12、13。我想我还有3本，所以我可能有15或16本。我有15或16本相册，而且我可能只做了最后三年的。她出生第一年我甚至还没动过。你知道，她才四岁，已经有17本书了。我得开始建立我自己的图书馆了。
Each scrapbook is several inches thick and bound in leather. They're like some mutant cross between a photo album and a journal. On one page, portraits of Maddie in a flowery, Easter dress and sun hat are matted on yellow and green, acid-free, archival quality papers. Then, cascading down into these abundant piles at the bottom of the page, are purple and yellow pansies, hundreds of them that Timi pressed from her own yard.
每一本剪贴簿都有好几英寸厚，用皮革装订。它们就像是相册和日记的某种突变杂交体。在一页上，麦迪穿着花哨的复活节裙子和太阳帽的肖像，被镶嵌在黄色和绿色的无酸、存档级纸张上。然后，倾泻在页面底部这些丰富的堆叠中，是紫色和黄色的三色堇，几百朵都是蒂米从自家院子里压出来的。
On another page, eight copies of the same photograph of Maddie at the beach in her little pink swimsuit are cut into triangles. The eight triangles are pasted around a central point, so you get the effect of looking through a kaleidoscope. In another layout, she scrapbooked Maddie on September 11th doing somersaults in front of the TV with pictures of the World Trade Center site flickering in the background.
在另一页上，麦迪在海滩上穿着粉色小泳衣的同一张照片，被剪成了八个三角形。这八个三角形围绕一个中心点粘贴，所以你会得到一种透过万花筒观察的效果。在另一个布局中，她剪贴了麦迪在9月11日那天在电视机前翻筋头的样子，背景中闪烁着世贸中心现场的照片。
Timi says she was struck by her daughter's innocence on this day when she, herself, thought the world was coming to an end. She matted the photos on red, white, and blue papers. The headline streaming above all this was taken from an Alan Jackson song, "Where were you on that September morn?"
蒂米说，那天她被女儿的天真所震撼，而她自己当时认为世界末日要到了。她把照片镶嵌在红、白、蓝纸张上。上方流动的标题取自艾伦·杰克逊的一首歌：“在那九月的早晨，你在哪里？”
On nearly every page, Timi also has brief journal entries mounted on contrasting patterned papers and printed out in fonts appropriate to the subject matter, curlicues for birthdays, calligraphy for more serious events. Timi has got a journal entry for every day since she first found out she was pregnant with Maddie. The day we visited, she had 1,765 in the hole. Here's one of them.
在几乎每一页上，蒂米还贴有简洁的日记条目，印在对比鲜明的图案纸上，并用适合主题的字体打印出来，生日用花体，更严肃的事件用书法。从蒂米第一次发现自己怀上麦迪的那天起，她为每一天都写了日记。我们拜访的那天，她日记库里有1765条。这是其中之一。
"January 26, 2001, you and I ran errands and shopped a big part of the day. You drew all over a card for your Papa Chase's birthday. I learned, today, that you now know how to open certain types of doors that have pull handles."
“2001年1月26日，你和我跑了腿，逛了大半天街。你在给你爸爸查斯的生日贺卡上画满了画。今天我才知道，你现在已经知道如何打开某些带有把手的门了。”
Reading these, one after another, page after page, is a little overwhelming, the sheer accumulation and tenacity. It's too complete, too much like real-life, all those mundane details.
一遍又一遍地阅读这些内容，一页接一页，让人有点不知所措，那是纯粹的积累和坚韧。它太完整了，太像现实生活了，全是那些平凡的细节。
"You went to gymnastics and took your kitty with you today."
“你今天去上体操课，还带上了你的小猫。”
Timi tells us that, when it comes to Maddie, nothing is mundane, that every little bit is important. She wants to capture it all.
蒂米告诉我们，当涉及到麦迪时，没有什么东西是平凡的，每一丁点都很重要。她想抓住这一切。
When my little girl kept going to all her doctor appointments every two months and getting all of her shots, as terrible as this sounds, I took my camera with me to the doctor's office and took pictures. I walk around all the time seeing scrapbook layouts everywhere I go. There are times I've seen Maddie just sitting on the doorstep, and one time in particular, and I saw her just staring intently. And I'm like, "What are you doing?" She goes, "I'm watching the butterfly." And so I went and grabbed my camera, and I wanted to take a picture of her just staring at the butterfly. At every moment, every corner I turn, there's a possible scrapbook layout.
当我女儿每两个月去一次医生预约并打预防针时，听起来很可怕，但我带着相机去了医生办公室并拍照。我随时随地都在观察着，随处可见剪贴簿的布局。有几次我看到麦迪只是坐在台阶上，特别是有一次，我看到她目不转睛地盯着。我说：“你在干什么？”她说：“我在看蝴蝶。”于是我去拿了相机，我想拍下她只是盯着蝴蝶的样子。每一刻，我转过每一个角落，都有一个可能的剪贴簿布局。
After Maddie was born, Timi found it more and more difficult to work full-time, be an attentive wife, raise her daughter, and scrapbook so seriously. So when Maddie was about two, Timi decided to quit her job as a paralegal. It may sound extreme to leave work in order to make expensive and elaborate scrapbooks that only your family will ever see. And the scrapbooking supplies are slowly taking over their house, but Gary, Timi's husband, just kind of shrugs at all that.
麦迪出生后，蒂米发现要兼顾全职工作、做一个贴心的妻子、抚养女儿和如此认真地做剪贴簿越来越困难。所以当麦迪两岁左右时，蒂米决定辞去律师助理的工作。为了制作昂贵而精美的剪贴簿，而这些剪贴簿只有你的家人会看到，辞去工作听起来可能很极端。而且剪贴簿用品正慢慢占据他们的房子，但蒂米的丈夫加里对这一切只是耸耸肩。
It's her house. I'm just living in it. I've got my remote control, my TV, and my chair. I have my own little closet, which I didn't have for a while. I only had half of that. I have the closet and one little spot on the dresser. That's me. The rest of the house is hers.
那是她的房子。我只是住在里面。我有我的遥控器、我的电视和我的椅子。我有我自己的小衣柜，这在我有一段时间没拥有过。我只有那一半。我有衣柜和梳妆台上的一小块地方。那就是我。房子的其余部分是她的。
Not that the scrapbooking doesn't worry him sometimes.
并不是说剪贴簿有时不会让他担心。
I mean, I don't know if that's good or bad.
我的意思是，我不知道这到底是好是坏。
What do you think? What would be good and what would be bad about it?
你觉得呢？关于这个，什么是好的，什么是坏的？
I think if you're always in the mode of trying to create a moment, sometimes, I think, you let moments pass by without really enjoying them. So her way to hold onto that is to create something that she can physically look at to remember that particular moment, maybe to recapture that feeling again. I always try to tell her, "Would you just relax, and sit down, and try to enjoy it?" You know? I mean, there's got to be some part that you take in, in your soul. In that respect, I feel bad for her because she's so worried about holding onto it that I don't know if she really ever captures it.
我觉得如果你总是处于试图创造某种时刻的模式中，有时，我觉得，你让时刻流逝而没有真正享受它们。所以她保持这种状态的方式就是创造出她可以亲眼看到的东西，来记住那个特定的时刻，也许是为了重新捕捉那种感觉。我总是试着告诉她：“你能不能放松一下，坐下来，试着去享受它？”你知道吗？我的意思是，必须有一些部分是你从灵魂中吸收的。在这方面，我为她感到难过，因为她太担心抓住它了，以至于我不知道她是否真正捕捉到了它。
Timi is so intent sometimes on capturing the moment that even if that moment somehow passes her by, she'll re-stage it in order to get the layout she wants. One Christmas, when her photos came back from the lab too dark, she actually fabricated the whole holiday season again. She dragged out all of her decorations, re-dressed Maddie in her various Christmas outfits, and took a bunch of photos over. Fortunately, the tree was still up.
蒂米有时太专注于捕捉那一刻，以至于如果那一刻以某种方式溜走，她会为了得到她想要的布局而重新编排它。有一个圣诞节，当她的照片从实验室冲洗出来太暗时，她竟然把整个节日季又重新炮制了一遍。她翻出了所有的装饰品，重新给麦迪换上各种圣诞装束，重拍了一大堆照片。幸运的是，树还在。
I remember that whole deal just because the fact that I couldn't believe that she was re-dressing Mattie back up in Christmas stuff for pictures because she thought that they didn't come out quite right. And if you would see the number of boxes we have for Christmas decorations, it is two closets full. And everything has to go back into its little box, wrapped up in bubble wrap, and put into the box, and it's like, oh, my God.
我记得整个过程，仅仅因为我无法相信她为了照片因为觉得效果不好，就把麦迪重新装扮回圣诞造型。如果你看到我们装饰圣诞节的盒子的数量，那是塞满了两个衣柜。每样东西都必须放回它的小盒子里，用气泡膜包好，放进盒子里，这简直是，天哪。
My husband thinks I'm out of control. I don't think I am out of control. But I think it's all in one's perspective. Most people look at me and go oh, my gosh, you're a bit excessive here. But we're all enjoying it. We're having fun. We're making scrapbooks for our children or our grandchildren. We're doing something creative. It's not like we're out Imelda Marcos and blowing all our money on shoes or something. So long as we get the laundry done, and the house clean, and the cooking done, who cares what we do with our spare time?
我丈夫认为我失控了。我不认为我失控了。但我认为这完全取决于个人的视角。大多数人看着我都会说，天哪，你这也太过了。但我们都在享受它。我们玩得很开心。我们正在为我们的孩子或孙子制作剪贴簿。我们在做一些有创意的事情。这又不是我们像伊梅尔达·马科斯那样把所有的钱都花在鞋子上什么的。只要我们洗完了衣服，房子打扫干净，饭做好了，谁在乎我们用业余时间做什么呢？
Do you think is there any negative repercussions on Maddie with the obsessive kind of nature of it?
你认为这种执着的本性对麦迪有没有负面影响？
There are times when I'm working on a project, I've got a deadline, and I'm stressed about it. And I'm sitting there grinding at the table trying to get this project done. And Maddie's saying, "But mommy, I want you to read me a book." And I'm saying, "I'll read you a book in a little while when I'm finished. I've got to get this done." And, when I think about it, I'm like, OK, now what's most important here, really? And, honestly, my daughter is most important. But there are times that I put her off when she really needs me or wants me because I'm working on scrapbooking. Now, that is the time that I think that's a negative.
有时当我在做一个项目时，我有最后期限，而且我为此感到压力。我坐在那里在桌子旁研磨，试图完成这个项目。麦迪说：“但妈妈，我想要你读本书给我听。”我说：“等我忙完了，一会儿就给你读。我得把这个做完。”而且，当我想到它时，我会想，好吧，现在这里最重要的是什么，真的？老实说，我的女儿最重要。但确实有几次，当她真正需要我或想要我时，我因为在做剪贴簿而推开了她。现在，那是我想那是负面影响的时候。
We asked Timi what she thinks it's about, her need to document her life so compulsively, and she's not sure at first. She gives different reasons at different times. She talks about how when she was nine, her grandmother died. She'd spent nearly every day of her life with her grandmother. A year later, her family pulled up stakes in West Virginia and moved to Houston where they knew no one.
我们问蒂米她觉得这是怎么回事，她强迫性地记录自己生活的需要，起初她也不确定。她在不同时间给出不同的理由。她谈到九岁时祖母去世了。她一生中几乎每天都和祖母在一起。一年后，她的家人拔掉在西弗吉尼亚州的根，搬到了休斯顿，那里他们谁也不认识。
Back east, she'd been surrounded by a large, extended family of great-grandparents, and grandparents, and aunts, and uncles, and cousins, who lived in little towns like Hurricane, and Dunbar, and Tater Creek. But a 1,000 miles from where she began, she was suddenly isolated from everything that had seemed vital and real. Her past seemed erased. Her parents began to fight, and they later divorced. Everything sort of fell apart. She hasn't seen her father in years. And all sorts of people close to her started dying off. And it's all this loss that Timi seems to be trying to fend off through her scrapbooks. It's almost like, if she can arrange life in these beautiful layouts, she can control it. And in visiting her, over the course of a few weeks, my co-producer, Julie, and I suggest that to her.
在东方，她身边环绕着庞大的大家庭，有曾祖父母、祖父母、阿姨、叔叔和表亲，他们住在像飓风镇、邓巴镇和塔特尔溪这样的小镇里。但在距离她开始生活的地方1000英里之外，她突然与所有显得重要和真实的东西隔绝了。她的过去似乎被擦掉了。她的父母开始吵架，后来离了婚。一切都分崩离析了。她已经多年没见过父亲了。而且所有亲近她的人都开始陆续去世。正是这种失落感，蒂米似乎正在试图通过剪贴簿来抵御。这几乎就像是，如果她能把生活安排在这些美丽的布局中，她就能控制它。在过去几周拜访她的过程中，我的联合制片人朱莉和我向她提出了这一点。
I've thought about that a great deal in the last week, about here I'm this person that has this death issue. I've known that for the longest time, but it never occurred to me that that could be what was the underlying, driving force making me almost feel possessed sometime about I've got to get this done. And I've got to hurry, you know? I want to get this all on paper. I've got it all written down. I've got to make sure I don't miss anything. And it never occurred to me that there was that deep of a link motivating me. So that's been very profound for me.
在过去的一周里，我对此想了很多，关于我这个有死亡焦虑问题的人。我知道这一点已经很久了，但从未想到这可能是潜在的、驱动的力量，让我有时感到着魔般地认为我必须把它完成。而且我必须赶快，你知道吗？我想把这一切都写在纸上。我已经把它全部写下来了。我必须确保我没有漏掉任何东西。而且从未想到我内心深处有那样的动机。所以这对我有很深刻的启发。
About 10 years ago, Timi's mother presented her with a plaster cast of Timi's hands back when Timi was six, a project she'd made when she was in the first grade. Her mother had saved it all these years.
大约10年前，蒂米的母亲给了她一个蒂米六岁时的手部石膏模型，那是她在一年级时做的一个项目。她母亲把这些东西都保存了这么多年。
I cried, and cried, and cried because it meant something to me that it was important enough to her to hold onto it, and keep it all those years, and give it back to me, and say, this is a part of your childhood. This was part of your life. I want you to hold on to this. It gives you roots. It gives you history. So I wanted to capture for Maddie who she was, where she came from, and what her life was like. And I assumed that she would be the same way, that it would be just as important for her.
我哭了，哭啊哭，因为它对我来说意味着某种东西，因为它对她来说足够重要，能坚持抓住它，保存这么多年，把它还给我，说，这是你童年的一部分。这是你生活的一部分。我想要你抓住它。它给了你根。它给了你历史。所以我想要为麦迪捕捉她是谁，她来自哪里，以及她的生活是什么样的。我以为她也会一样，这对她来说也会同样重要。
But I can't quit. I don't know why. I don't know. It's partially out of guilt. I know this sounds silly, but it's not. It's almost as if I stop, then it says, I don't care enough to write, or I'm too busy in my day that I can't fill up a 1 and 1/2 inch square about your life. And I just feel too guilty to stop. It's like once I got started, I can't quit.
但我停不下来。我不知道为什么。我不知道。部分是出于愧疚。我知道这听起来很傻，但事实并非如此。这几乎就像如果我停下来，它就在说，我不够在乎去写，或者我太忙于一天的时间以至于无法填满关于你生活的一平方半英寸。我因为愧疚而无法停止。这就像一旦我开始，我就停不下来。
So the big news is that Timi is pregnant again. She has a baby boy on the way in just a few months, and this has put her in an untenable position. She's not sure there are enough hours in the day to scrapbook for two children. If you've decided that scrapbooks are how you show your love for your child, what does it say about your love if you stop scrapbooking? Timi has sort of scrapbooked herself into a corner.
所以大新闻是蒂米又怀孕了。她再过几个月就要生个男婴了，这把她置于一个难以为继的境地。她不确定一天中是否有足够的时间为两个孩子做剪贴簿。如果你决定了剪贴簿是你展示对孩子爱的方式，那么如果你停止做剪贴簿，这说明你的爱怎么样？蒂米算是把自己逼到了死角。
I have not journaled even a fraction to this baby what I did for Maddie, and that's really been bothering me. And even in my journal, I have written to the baby trying to explain why I have not journaled as much, and please don't take this personally when you get older and read your journal and wonder why your mommy didn't write very much to you.
我写给这个孩子的日记连给麦迪的一小部分都没有，这真的让我很困扰。甚至在日记里，我写信给宝宝，试图解释为什么我没有写那么多日记，请你长大后读日记、好奇为什么你妈妈没为你写很多东西时，不要往心里去。
Timi is trying to finish up this scrapbook of Maddie's first year before the new baby is born in October. She says that this scrapbook will be about 100 pages long. So far, she's done 12 pages. Every two-page layout takes her 10 to 12 hours to do. That's nearly 1,000 hours of work, 40 straight days, all scrapbooking, no sleep. The new baby is due in 10 weeks. She's not sure she's going to make it.
蒂米正试图在十月新宝宝出生前完成麦迪第一年的这本剪贴簿。她说这本剪贴簿大约有100页长。到目前为止，她做了12页。每一页两页布局需要她花10到12个小时来做。那几乎是1000个小时的工作，40天不间断，全部做剪贴簿，不睡觉。新宝宝还有10周就到了。她不确定她能否完成。
Kim Meyer and her co-producer, Julie Checkoway, live in Houston. Their website, storyrodeo.org.
金·迈耶和她的联合制片人朱莉·切科韦住在休斯顿。他们的网站，storyrodeo.org。
Act Three, Slingshot. John Hodgman has this letter, which he wrote years ago and which he agreed to read on our program, about the changes that can happen from one summer to the next.
第三幕，“弹弓”。约翰·霍奇曼有这封信，那是他多年前写的，他同意在我们的节目中朗读，关于从一个夏天到下一个夏天可能发生的改变。
Dear Mary, here is all that need be said about my experience gambling in Atlantic City. At the Trump Taj Mahal I played $1 to $3 seven-card stud for four hours, sipping free whisky and making jokes with strangers, and I lost all of $7. Then I played slots and lost seven times that in a quick, mean, and lonely 40 minutes. As they say, easy come, easy go.
亲爱的玛丽，这就是关于我在大西洋城赌博体验所需说的一切。在特朗普泰姬陵赌场，我玩了四个小时的1美元到3美元七张牌梭哈，喝着免费威士忌，和陌生人开玩笑，结果我输了7美元。然后我玩了老虎机，在快速、卑劣而孤独的40分钟里，输掉了七倍的钱。就像他们说的，来得容易去得快。
It's tempting to use gambling as a metaphor when writing about the Jersey Shore. But I would rather discuss the metaphoric power of the Slingshot, which stands at 8th and Boardwalk, a handful of miles south of the Taj, in Ocean City, New Jersey. Like all good metaphors, the Slingshot is versatile and may be seen from many different angles. It is seen first, and from afar, as two enormous towers lit with neon, 100 feet high above the boardwalk and the ocean beyond. As you get closer, you see that between them is suspended a spherical cage that rotates freely around its horizontal axis, where cables stretch from either side to the tips of the two towers. There are two seats inside the sphere that, after a hydraulic mechanism tightens the cables, carry two occupants 200 feet into the air at 100 miles per hour, while spinning.
在书写泽西海岸时，使用赌博作为隐喻很诱人。但我宁愿讨论“弹弓”的隐喻力量，它位于新泽西州大洋城，在第8街和木板路旁，距离泰姬陵以南几英里。像所有好的隐喻一样，“弹弓”用途广泛，可以从许多不同的角度来看。首先，从远处看，它是两座霓虹灯照亮的巨大塔楼，矗立在木板路和更远处的海洋之上100英尺高处。当你靠近时，你会看到它们之间悬挂着一个球形笼子，绕着它的水平轴自由旋转，电缆从两侧延伸到两座塔楼的尖端。球体内有两个座位，在液压机构收紧电缆后，载着两名乘客在旋转的同时，以每小时100英里的速度升入200英尺的高空。
It is the sort of thing that its creators bill as a ride. It is the sort of thing that, when seen from the ground at the very base of the towers, inspires one 14-year-old girl with very large teeth to somberly explain to her girlfriend, "I'm not saying that you're going to die. I'm just saying that, if you do die, it was meant to be."
这是那种其创造者称为“游乐设施”的东西。它是那种当从塔底的地面看到时，启发了一位长着大牙齿的14岁女孩忧郁地向她的女友解释：“我不是说你一定会死。我只是说，如果你真的死了，那是命中注定的。”
The summer before this one, we were fearless. In 1999, Katherine and I came to Ocean City for an engagement party that my mother and her five sisters threw for us on the deck of my Aunt Susan's summer home. We opened presents until dusk fell. Then Katherine and I hiked down to the main drag of the boardwalk and took on everything the amusement parks had to offer: the Giant Ferris Wheel, The Inverter, The City Jet, The Spanish Galleon, Katherine's favorite. We were thrown, and twisted, and twirled, and Katherine almost got sick but didn't. My grandmother was alive then, and so was my mother.
那个夏天之前，我们是无畏的。1999年，凯瑟琳和我来到大洋城参加一场订婚派对，我母亲和她的五个姐妹在我苏珊姨妈的避暑别墅露台上为我们举办了派对。我们拆礼物直到黄昏降临。然后凯瑟琳和我徒步走到木板路的主路，挑战了游乐园所能提供的一切：巨大的摩天轮、反转机、城市喷气机、西班牙大帆船，凯瑟琳的最爱。我们被抛起、扭转、旋转，凯瑟琳差点吐了，但没吐。那时我祖母还活着，我母亲也是。
Several weeks after we left, there was an accident on a new roller coaster at Wonderland Pier, The Wild Wonder. One car slammed into another at high speed. And two occupants, a young woman from New York and her very young child, were thrown from their restraints. They flew out of the car through the air and into a steel support beam. They died instantly.
我们离开几周后，Wonderland Pier的一个新过山车“狂野奇迹”发生了事故。一辆车高速撞上了另一辆车。两名乘客，一名来自纽约的年轻女性和她非常年幼的孩子，从约束装置中被甩了出来。他们飞出了车子，穿过空气，撞在了一根钢支撑梁上。他们当场死亡。
As well, as you may recall from my last letter, my grandmother died the following Christmas. And my mother died the following June, six days after my birthday, both quickly, both with little warning. And then, in August, we returned to Ocean City. People asked, will it be hard going back without your mother? And I had no answer. The same non-answer I had and have to any question about how hard it is or it will be now that all these things have happened. Jesus, I don't know. Let's go to the boardwalk.
同样，正如你可能从我上一封信中回忆起的那样，我祖母在接下来的圣诞节去世了。我母亲在接下来的六月，在我生日后六天去世了，都很快，都没什么预兆。然后，在八月，我们回到了大洋城。人们问，没有你母亲回去会很难吗？我没有答案。和我对所有关于这些事情发生后会有多难的问题一样，我没有答案。天哪，我不知道。咱们去木板路吧。
When we got to Wonderland Pier, no one seemed to feel the chill haunt of the roller coaster deaths but us. I watched the children in the little cars fly into the air and I cringed. I watched the teenagers necking on the Giant Ferris Wheel with its rust spots and strange creakings. Just looking at the Double Dip at Playland made my neck hurt. But it was the Slingshot that sent us packing.
当我们到达Wonderland Pier时，似乎除了我们之外，没人感觉到过山车死亡带来的寒意。我看着小车里的孩子们飞向空中，我畏缩了。我看着十几岁的少男少女在生锈、吱吱作响的巨大摩天轮上亲热。仅仅看着Playland的“双重下坠”就让我的脖子疼。但正是“弹弓”让我们打道回府。
The Slingshot is not affiliated with either Wonderland or Playland. The Slingshot stands alone. Couple after couple are sent screaming into the black, summer night, becoming a tiny, star-like spark against the sky, cables heaving, towers wobbling, sphere becoming invisible. It was the Slingshot that made us feel too old, too scared, and suddenly vulnerable. Katherine has said that, when she was a child, she loved all amusement park rides because she knew that they were made by grownups, which to her meant endless safety and boundless security. Naturally, we have outgrown that delusion.
“弹弓”与Wonderland或Playland都没有关联。“弹弓”独自矗立。一对又一对情侣尖叫着冲入黑色的夏夜，变成天空中微小、星光般的火花，电缆起伏，塔楼晃动，球体变得不可见。正是“弹弓”让我们感到太老、太害怕，而且突然变得脆弱。凯瑟琳说，当她还是个孩子时，她喜欢所有的游乐园设施，因为她知道它们是大人做的，对她来说这意味着无尽的安全和无边的保障。自然，我们已经长大了，不再有那种幻觉。
As we trudged back from the boardwalk in defeat, we saw the moon over the beach. Or, at least, we thought it was the moon. It hovered just above the inky horizon, blood red, engorged, larger than the sun at dawn, too bloated to hoist itself any further in the sky and more likely about to fall. A small crowd had actually gathered by the boardwalk's rail to gawk at it as though it were a fleet of invading space ships. And Katherine and I joined them. "Either that's the moon," someone behind us said, "or something has gone horribly, horribly wrong."
当我们垂头丧气地从木板路走回来时，我们看到了海滩上的月亮。或者至少，我们以为那是月亮。它悬浮在墨色的地平线上方，血红色的，充血，比黎明时的太阳还要大，肿胀得无法再在天空中抬升更高，而且更有可能即将坠落。一大群人甚至聚集在木板路的栏杆旁盯着它，就好像那是一支入侵的宇宙飞船编队。凯瑟琳和我加入了他们。“那要么是月亮，”身后有人说，“要么就是出了什么可怕的可怕的问题。”
So now it's the next night, the night after the moon, and Katherine and I have returned to the Slingshot. The large-toothed girl behind us in line says her piece about death and destiny, and we clutch our non-refundable tickets with panic and regret. We watch that spherical cage ascend and descend for nearly 45 minutes. We watch children no older than 10 be happily loaded into what we come to call the ascending sphere of death. And then we're next.
所以现在是第二天晚上，月亮出现后的那一晚，凯瑟琳和我回到了“弹弓”。排在我们后面那个大牙女孩说了关于死亡和命运的话，我们带着恐慌和遗憾紧紧抓住不可退款的门票。我们看着那个球形笼子升起和降下近45分钟。我们看着不到10岁的孩子快乐地被装进我们所说的“死亡上升球体”里。然后就轮到我们了。
It is difficult to explain what has drawn us here after our cowardly retreat last night. We have every excuse not to be here, from the metaphysical to the financial. It costs $20 a head to fly. This alone should chase off a cheapskate like me. But we are here at Katherine's impulsive suggestion and my impulsive agreement, and neither one of us wants to back down. We want to be able to say we will not be cowed by death.
很难解释昨晚我们怯懦撤退后是什么吸引了我们来到这里。我们有充分的借口不去那里，从形而上学到财务方面。飞一次要20美元一人。单单这一点就应该赶走像我这样的吝啬鬼。但我们在这里，在凯瑟琳冲动的建议和我不假思索的同意下，我们谁也不想退缩。我们想要能够说，我们不会被死亡吓倒。
But we also see very clearly the weak links in the Slingshot chain, the points where the cable may break or the tower may buckle. The whole rig is set back from the boardwalk in the semi-dark of 8th Street. Though enormous, it has the look of something that really shouldn't be there, of something that can be broken down and carted away very quickly should the sheriff show up wanting to know, "What's all this about a Slingshot then?"
但我们也清楚地看到了“弹弓”链条上的薄弱环节，电缆可能断裂或塔楼可能弯曲的点。整个装置坐落在第8街半黑暗中，远离木板路。虽然庞大，但它看起来就像那种真的不应该在那里的东西，那种如果警长出现想知道“所有关于弹弓的这些是什么”时，可以迅速拆除并运走的东西。
There is a palpable air of unease around us, as though all of us in line can, perhaps too easily, envision something snapping this time, the ball flying up and disappearing into the night, crashing miles away in the ocean, perhaps, or a parking lot. And if not this time, the next time. I did not tell Katherine this and really haven't considered it until now. But we are there too, I think, not just to defy death, but to welcome it.
我们周围有一种明显的焦虑气氛，就好像我们排队的所有人都能，也许太容易地，想象出这次会发生断裂，球飞起来并消失在夜空中，可能坠落在几英里外的海里，或者停车场。即使不是这次，也是下次。我没把这个告诉凯瑟琳，实际上直到现在才考虑到它。但我认为我们在那里，不仅仅是为了蔑视死亡，也是为了迎接它。
It has been a hard year. It has been an unfair year in which we have been taught to think of the unthinkable, taught that we are not exempt from tragedy, but, in fact, can be its strange attractors. It's not quite a suicide pact, but I think that we share an agreement, unspoken even to ourselves, that if this thing kills us, we could live with that, so to speak.
这是艰难的一年。这是不公平的一年，在这一年里，我们被教导去思考不可想象的事情，教导我们并非免于悲剧，事实上，我们可能是它的奇怪吸引子。这不完全是一份自杀契约，但我认为我们有一个协议，即使对我们自己来说也是未说出口的，如果这玩意儿杀了我们，我们能接受，可以这么说。
When our turn comes, there's a strange ritual to it. We empty our pockets into a plastic bin: wallets, change, keys, salt water taffy, Katherine's flip-flops. I take my glasses off and give them to the man who will prepare us for the ride. I swear he has a handlebar mustache. He tells us we can take nothing with us. We sit in the cage. The mustachioed man arranges the nylon straps and restraining bars that hold us in place. One of them goes directly across my crotch, but I am not embarrassed to have him help me there. I am beyond such modesties. "Tighter," I say. He closes the cage and gives it a friendly tap. "It'll be over before you know it," he says.
当轮到我们时，有一个奇怪的仪式。我们把口袋里的东西倒进一个塑料桶里：钱包、零钱、钥匙、盐水太妃糖、凯瑟琳的人字拖。我摘下眼镜，交给那个为我们要骑车做准备的人。我发誓他有车把手那样的胡子。他告诉我们什么都不能带。我们坐在笼子里。那个有胡子的男人布置好把我们固定在位置上的尼龙带和约束杆。其中一个直接横过我的胯部，但我并不为他帮我那里感到尴尬。我已超越了那种羞涩。“紧一点，”我说。他关上笼子，轻敲了一下，以示友好。“你还没反应过来就会结束的，”他说。
The cage tilts back and is locked into a release switch below. We are facing directly upwards now. There are no stars. They are blotted out by the lights of the boardwalk. The towers hum as the cables tighten. I take Katherine's hand. "Pretend we're going into space," I say. "That is not a comfort," she says. The hum grows very loud. The cables grow very tight. Katherine takes her hand back. She wants to hold the restraint. A switch somewhere is thrown, and we go up.
笼子向后倾斜，被锁定在下面的释放开关里。我们现在正直接向上看。没有星星。它们被木板路的灯光遮住了。塔楼在电缆收紧时发出嗡嗡声。我握住凯瑟琳的手。“假装我们要进入太空，”我说。“那可不是一种安慰，”她说。嗡嗡声变得非常响。电缆变得非常紧。凯瑟琳抽回了她的手。她想抓住约束装置。某处的开关被拨动了，我们就飞了上去。
As metaphors for life and death on the boardwalk go, gambling in Atlantic City is pretty promising. But the Slingshot is better for two reasons. One, though it is unlikely, it may actually kill you. And two, it reminds you that when you are close to death and intimate with it, when you are spinning fast and high in the dark night with nothing around you, it is difficult to tell what is happening. It is difficult to be afraid, far more difficult than it is on the ground.
作为木板路上关于生与死的隐喻，在大西洋城赌博相当有希望。但“弹弓”更好，原因有二。第一，虽然不太可能，但它确实可能会杀了你。第二，它提醒你，当你接近死亡并与它亲密接触时，当你和你在黑暗的夜晚里旋转得如此快和高，周围什么都没有时，很难分辨发生了什么。很难害怕，比在地面上要困难得多。
John Hodgman runs The Little Gray Books Lecture Series in New York. His letter once appeared at openletters.net.
约翰·霍奇曼在纽约主持“小灰书讲座系列”。他的信曾出现在openletters.net上。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
You can download audio of our show at audible.com/thisamericanlife where they have Public Radio programs, best selling books, even the New York Times all at audible.com.
你可以在audible.com/thisamericanlife下载我们节目的音频，那里有公共广播节目、畅销书籍，甚至纽约时报，都在audible.com。
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
《美国生活》由公共广播国际发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助鸣谢]
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia who finds himself fascinated, fascinated, by the phrase--
WBEZ的管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚负责，他发现自己对这个词组着迷，着迷于——
Big, sloppy glops of poop.
大块、粘糊糊的粪便。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
PRI. Public Radio International.
PRI。公共广播国际。